il pêche ta maman est sans compte
là-bas aussi
mais tu ne vas pas être un jour
mieux vas-y non yo
donc tu veux être un chanteur
comment tu sais que tout ce qu'ils veulent être
tu ne peux pas avoir un problème  tout
le temps continuez à me faire signer un miracle
vraiment
peut-être que moi et toi aurions pu faire un
peu d'harmonie ensemble venir maman
tu viens regarder ces gens James
qu'est-ce que ça va être quand nous mettrons à jour le livre
ce qui ne va pas ne peut pas jouer à ce vélo tu
nous l'as dit  ne fonctionne pas musicalement
ne sonne pas bien est-ce que ça fait du bien
vous entrez dans un jeu ici où les
règles sont déjà établies Je ne suis qu'un
enfant de la rue d'Augusta Georgia maintenant dites-
moi ce que vous voyez nous avons la pluie est super
pop lourde - les chats là-bas tu
veux descendre deux accrocs l'homme pour
tuer [ __ ] il y a une femme ici GC g
yo mama mon bébé joue à l'Apollo
n'est-ce pas ton bébé les gens feraient mieux d'être prêts
plus vite qu'un téléphone à ondes chaque homme est  en
marche plus grand parce que c'était James Brown avons-
nous fait mr.  chauve-souris, je crains que non mr.  marron
j'ai dit que nous avons fini je pense que nous avons plus de
funk dans l'auge
ouvre tes oreilles oh bon Dieu